في نهايه عام 2017 اطلقت الممثله
الامريكيه اليسا مليانو هاشتاج ميتو للكشف
عن اسماء المتحرشين ومرتكبي جرائم
الاعتداء الجنسي منذ ذلك الحين وخرجت
العديد من القضايا منهم المنتج الامريكي
الذي حكم عليه بالسجن لمده سته عشر عاما
ضمن قضيه اتهامه بالاعتداء على 90 فنانه
في قضيه شرف هزت الوسط الفني منذ ست سنوات
هناك ايضا الممثل كافيني سبيسي الحائز على
جائزه الاوسكار الذي يواجه الدعاءات
باعتداءه جنسيا على فتى قبل 36 عاما
ويواجه ايضا خمساتها منفصله بالاعتداء
الجنسي في بريطانيا حتى الممثل مورجان
فريمان الذي اعتزل التمثيل بعد تكرار
اتهامات التحرش الجنسي وسوء السلوك من
ثماني سيدات ايضا الممثله
اليسا ارجنتو
ادعى عليها الممثل الشاب جيمي بنت بالتحرش
به جنسيا وهو في سن 17 عاما وفي عالم
الرياضه طالت مزاحم الاغتصاب البرتغالي
رونالدو والبرازيلي نيمار ماسون جرينو
واخرهم المغربي اشرف حكيمي وغيرهم بالرغم
من براءه بعض اللاعبين من مثل هذه
الاتهامات الا ان بعضهم ودينه ودخلوا
السجن لفتره ليست بالقصيره ابرزهم كان ادم
جونسون لاعب مانشستر سيتي الاسبق
[موسيقى]